101 degree night the dodgers would like
to remind all the cardboard cutouts to
remain hydrated
still have a sense of humor
tony gonzalen who makes his fifth start
of the season just one run and 17 and
two thirds thus far very comfortable now
that he knows that he's in the rotation
but that comfort comes in between starts
right now he has to compete with these
pitches rimel tapio gets toppy over to
fastball
opponents against tony gonzalez
fastwater now 5 for 35 this year trevor
story coming up 2-2 pitch and story
watches a splitter for strike three he
gets tapia swinging with a fastball he
gets story looking for the split change
to up two down brings up nolan arenado
tries to lay off but went around and
tony gonzalon strikes out the side in
the first inning here is airmon marcus
now against the dodgers has a 254 earned
run average against the dodgers all time
spooky bets will lead things off for la
for the one
after marquez have gotten ahead of him
he loses him on a lead off base running
rory seeger stepping in riding a
seven-game hitting streak strike three
called good pitch by ermond he froze
seeger and that's a big first down he
gets max muncie now this is back in the
middle of the diamond trevor to nolan
spinning throwing double play nolan's
hanging around out on the field i don't
know why that should be any ending
double play are we missing something
aaronato took the throw but he was not
on the bag and very alertly
looky ben saw hey nobody home at third
base he's campered over there your
nightly reminder that it's a lot of fun
to watch mookie bets play baseball he's
at third with two out for bellinger and
bellinger grounds it to second garrett
hampson has it on over to daniel murphy
good job by
ermond to work around that no play at
second base who's charlie blackman to
lead off the second blackman has been
mired in
charlie swings drives it towards right
bets will have to play it off the wall
blackman on his way to second he'll be
in there standing
charlie blackman with a leadoff double
here's pillar cracks one in the air to
right center bets going back on it still
going at the track at the wall to make
the catch now the transition he loses it
charlie is going to score how do you
like that it was a wonderful catch by
bench but then as he grabbed the ball
out of the glove he dropped it and the
rockies have the game's first run two
out double for gavin lux let's see what
edwin rios can do fly ball center field
pilar started back now kevin comes in
makes the grab and the double does no
damage tying run is in scoring position
with two gun here's muncie with a chance
to tie the score with a base hit swing
and a shot to center field pallar racing
back he's at the wall and he makes the
catch right in front of the barrier
long fly ball out does the job for
marcus and the rockies here's charlie
blackman bases empty one down he's
trying to get a little bit more done
against tony gonzalen offensively this
ball crushed to right bets look it up it
is
fair homerun
charlie blackman with the home run the
rockies lead it two to nothing cody
bellinger the cleanup band for the
dodgers to see what he can do against
airmon marcus swats this one high and
deep to right field hillyard
makes a catch sam hilliard with a
brilliant catch going above the barrier
in right field can you believe that
brings up batsman and third two guys
oogie of course throughout his career
has been a terrific hitter with runners
in scoring position that's to left a
base hit to give the dodgers their first
run of the night betts has been out all
three times tying on a board through
secret line drive right center base hits
seeger it makes its way to the wall
that's hits third and comes home and the
dodgers have tied it with two gun in the
fifth gasping for air on this hot night
boston barnes is gonna have a two out
double now you have to deal with bookie
bets bud blacks to the mound he has not
gone to the bullpen yet so black decides
to stay with marquez swung on hit in the
air right field hilliard moving to his
left underneath it makes the catch good
job by airman marcus to retire bets and
close the door in the seventh the
rockies have runners at first and third
and nobody out in the night nolan
arenado looking for his first hit
against the dodgers this year the ground
through the right side that'll work base
hit and the rockies take the lead they
put polar on intentionally and now bud
black sends up josh fuentes line drive
fair ball down the line that'll score at
least two fuentes coming through rockies
lead it five to two closer daniel bart
is on for the rockies dodgers down to
their final out rios another left-handed
batter is the hitter rio swings at the
first pitch sends it to
left center field rymel tapia's got it
and that's the ball game rockies in
their skid against la 5-2 they win it